so about a week ago Paramount Pictures
released the first look of the new
live-action ghost Michelle movie
starring Scarlett Johansson prompting
the internet to explode in a massive fit
of anger and rage of cause of racism and
misrepresentation against Scarlett
Johansson and the studio behind her full
of fact that a white woman is playing
someone called motoko kusanagi
funnily enough I've seen many people get
riled up about this but less so in our
own anomie community so I wanted to
address some points that I think me and
a lot of the community are actually
thinking it seems like many people
speaking up have not even seen any
iterations of ghost Michelle and instead
sort of named motoko kusanagi affiliated
with a white character and flipped their
[ __ ] in the process completely missing
the point of the story so for those of
you who have no idea what ghost in the
show is about here's some context ghost
Michelle is an anime film that was
released in 1995 that instantly became a
cult classic and a household name in the
medium of anime the world of ghosts in
the show set in a futuristic place where
technology has evolved to a point where
you can replace any and every part of
your body with prosthetics right down to
your brain the plot mostly revolves
around a special task for solving
various cyber crimes in this feature is
exciting while in the process posing
some deep philosophical questions along
the way such as if every part of your
body can be replaced with prosthetics
where would your soul resides hence the
term ghost in the shell' the task force
itself is spearheaded by motoko kusanagi
aka the major the major is an
interesting character while she is one
of the few strong female leads in anime
and has a Japanese name her origins
remain mostly a mystery and her body is
completely cybernetic meaning she could
have had any look she wanted created for
her her shell doesn't need to look
Japanese or Asian in the slightest and I
mention this because throughout her
history with the anime and manga her
Paris has been completely ethnically
neutral in actuality we could have
omitted her name entirely and simply
called her the major as most people
already refer to as in anime and manga
and we would have absolutely no idea
where she's actually from so having
someone like Scarlett Johansson player
isn't completely out of the question
there is nothing inherently Japanese
behind the central themes of the story
besides the fact that it's set in Japan
and there are Japanese characters in it
you could probably take some of these
themes and set it anywhere and it would
still be a great story oh wait I don't
even need to speculate this because
Hollywood has already done that once
it's for this reason that goes to the
show has managed to gain such a
worldwide
going behind it it's white ethnically
neutral stories like attack on Titan
death note of Dragon Ball and full metal
alchemist have a much easier time
expanding outside Japan it's because the
plot lines and characters are so
universally appealing that it doesn't
really matter where they take place or
who plays them the fact is that in this
far more globalized future where
technology has connected literally
everyone around the world a cyborg named
motoko kusanagi
living in a Caucasian body may not be
the most bizarre plot point I can think
of or are we going to call every Asian
person living here with a Western name a
fake because they don't look white
enough let's not forget that at the end
of the day this is a Western adaptation
with a Western company if a Japanese
company wanted to adapt something like
say I don't know attack on Titan then
I'm sure everyone would have problems
with the fact that they use an or
Japanese cars even though plot-wise only
one of the characters is ethnically
Japanese right right but giga i hear you
say this isn't about a white character
having an asian name it's about the
blatant whitewashing in hollywood and
Yun the appreciation of Asian actors and
actresses and so that's I say that's not
how the film industry works let me
preface with this I do think
whitewashing an Asian representation is
an issue in Hollywood but it's a much
deeper problem that people give it
credit for to start off with let's
ignore the whole debacle about Studios
testing CGI to make people look more
Asian as this is just a stupid and
borderline racist idea no matter how you
spin it and let's talk about the much
bigger the lemma that Studios had to
deal with to begin with movies need to
make money studios will not fund a movie
that doesn't look like it will be
profitable and what's the easiest way to
market a movie before it's even made
hire an a-list actor or actress
simply put Scarlett Johansson is one of
the few female actresses that can sell
tickets through name alone and with our
track records are playing sexy badass
strong female leads to play a sexy
badass strong female character it looks
on paper like we found someone who has a
good balance between marketability and a
proven track record now with this in
mind what Asian actress would be more
suitable for this role well I guess is
Rinko Kikuchi even though you know her
English isn't the most fluent yet and
most people only know her as that one
chick from Pacific Rim know what about
Ziyi Zhuang Olivia Munn Lucy Liu oh wait
they're of Chinese descent and I'm sure
we wouldn't want to spark a whole other
racial discussion about hiring
Chinese people to represent Japanese
characters as we know all Asians are the
same and the Japanese have a proven
track record to be happy with that
decision the fact of the matter is that
there is not enough of a pool of
high-profile Asian actresses to carry a
high profile movie and without a
big-name backing this this movie
wouldn't have been made in the first
place the fact that the studio got
Scarlett Johansson shows us at least
that they want to put in enough money
for it to succeed because the last thing
we need is another Dragonball Evolution
or The Last Airbender the only time in
recent memory that unknowns have been
casted in the big film is with Star Wars
and ice cuz the franchise name was big
enough to carry itself let's be real
here
even though ghosts this shows a massive
franchise in anime anime still a niche
medium even making an anime adaptation
in itself is a huge risk for movie
studios so they're going to want
something more than just the name ghost
in the shell' to sell the movie it's the
same reason exodus Godin Kings hide
Christian Bale to play Moses and Prince
of Persia hide Jake Gyllenhaal to play a
Persian prince and if you think the
Japanese care about this issue from the
looks of it they really don't instead of
ruling over the choice of this one movie
why not promote Hollywood to take on
more Asian oriented stories that would
give opportunities for more Asian
representation because let's turn us
around and I'm talking to you anime fans
this is the first time that any a list
celebrity has attached their name to a
direct live action anime IP and on
itself as a step not a huge one but it
at least shows that Hollywood is taking
notice and I don't expect them to just
open this floodgate straight away for
anime at the end of the day this was
never about ghost in the shell' getting
a live-action adaptations because
whether motoko kusanagi is black white
asian Hispanic or whatever
it won't affect whether this is a good
adaptation or not it may suck for all we
know
or it could be great and in the end
isn't this what it should be about
Bobo said
it's anguish